moi je pense que c'est un vide
être expulsé des forces armées
canadiennes surtout pour mauvaise
conduite place les anciens combattants
dans une situation d'extrême
vulnérabilité
c'est comme sauter en parachute
d'enlever sans trop savoir ce qui va
avoir encore des motards criminels en
profite pour les recruter d'après nos
informations une enquête le projet net
work a donc été lancé par la police
militaire pour surveiller le
comportement des groupes de
motocyclistes formée de soldats actifs
et d'anciens combattants qui
entretiennent des liens avec des gangs
de motards hors la loi la grande
majorité des membres qui font des mondes
armées canadiennes et des enseignements
des forces armées canadiennes qui font
partie des clubs sont parfaitement
légitimes
il ya une petite un petit pourcentage
qui pourrait possiblement poser un
risque à la sécurité
de nombreuses questions se posent
d'après la police militaire en ce qui
concerne les risques de conflit
d'intérêts mais aussi d'infiltration des
forces armées c'est possible qu'il y ait
un risque à la sécurité de l'institution
et lorsqu'il y aurait ce que
l'institution est aussi un risque à la
carrière du le rapport précise que les
membres des forces armées canadiennes
présente un intérêt pour les groupes de
motards criminels en raison de leur
accès aux armes ou munitions et aux
explosé ainsi que de leur entraînement
militaire en 2015
radio canada révélait que des anciens
combattants ont bel et bien été recrutés
par des groupes de motards qui appuient
les hells angels
un phénomène qui se poursuit selon nos
informations un ancien officier
d'expérience des forces armées est
notamment devenu un membre en règle des
bf messengers m6 un groupe de motards
québécois affilié aux hells angels
ce signal d'alarmé faut agir ce colonel
à la retraite estime que les règlements
militaires doivent être appliquées pour
interdire les liens des soldats avec des
motards criminels
je sais pas si l'autorité militaire
respect du moins ont pris des mesures
nécessaires dans un premier temps pour
laisser savoir ou au suc sont en service
actif que ceci n'est pas permis et pas
seulement de ne pas permis mais al
venant que des gens
par ses auteurs ce règlement à ce niveau
les diamants là des mesures
disciplinaires votre entreprise la
police militaire admet d'emblée qu'elle
n'a pas identifiés d'activités
criminelles organisées faites par les
groupes de motocyclistes formé de
militaires mais elle dit aussi que les
activités individuelles de certains
membres sont préoccupantes et pourrait
indiquer un problème plus important ici
guillaume dumont radio canada ottawa